>>Darren: The swine-flu snake
greeting, Morning, Morning, Morning,
Morning, Morning, Morning.
>>Narrator: At Carrithers
Middle School, the day begins
with goofy games, which are often
followed by serious discussions.
>>Darren: We've been discussing
bullying all week long.
What are some ways that
we can stop the bullying?
>>Narrator: The 20 minutes spent
in this daily morning meeting
is a critical component
of Jefferson County,
Kentucky's, district-wide CARE
for Kids initiative, which
seeks to build positive,
caring learning communities.
>>Darren: Humor?
That's always good, right?
What do you think humor
takes away from bullying?
>>Student: If you make
somebody laugh,
then they won't be as
angry as they were.
>>Sheldon: It takes skill
to lead a class meeting,
an effective class meeting, takes the
ability to not intervene too soon...
>>Darren: Or should we
maybe let Mr. Atkinson know?
What should we do about that?
>>Sheldon: ...to not impose one's
own values and one's own thoughts
on the situation and let
students engage and discuss
and struggle for a while.
>>Darren: I think that's a good idea.
>>Narrator: Fortunately,
there is support for teachers
who lead these difficult discussions.
They receive a binder of instructions
and activities and two days
of training in the summer, followed
by five follow-up sessions
throughout the year.
>>Teacher: One of the challenges
for me was changing
how I saw consequences
and the proactive approach.
>>Teacher: And, I mean, I think
that's what I see you all -
if you struggle with
anything, it's the language,
because it is so different
than corrective language.
It's all the negative of "don't
do that," "don't do this,"
"this is what you did wrong,"
whereas the language and care
and developmental designs is
all about self-regulation,
about acknowledging what you've done.
It's all in a positive.
It's non-confrontational.
So, is that what you
all see as the language
as probably the biggest change?
>>Alicia: Some teachers, the CARE for
Kids might come naturally for them.
For others it might
be more of a struggle.
The framework is there.
They can pick up the book and
structure their morning meeting
and afternoon meeting
using the resources,
and so it's helped everyone quickly
be able to implement it successfully.
>>Teacher: There are some things
that're already in place in the book
that we may want to
consider instead of some
of these levels that
we currently have.
>>Narrator: Every school has a
CARE for Kids leadership team,
usually comprised of the principal
and a representative
from each grade level.
>>Teacher: Mr. Atkinson, would
you like to join our circle?
>>Darren: Sure, I'd
love to, thank you.
>>Narrator: As the Care team leader
at Carrithers, Darren Atkinson acts
as a sounding board and
mentor for his colleagues.
>>Darren: Well, I think
your circles go well.
The kids all seem to
interact very well.
They communicate.
>>My job is to find out if they
have any kind of issues at hand,
and then if I can help them solve
that, then that's where I try
to either suggest the advisory
books or a Web site or something
that we found successful
in another school.
Whatever I can do to
alleviate their issue
and whatever problems they're seeing
at the time, that's kind of my role.
>>I would have a fix-it plan
and just explain to him,
"This is what I'm seeing.
Please help me to understand
why that this is happening."
>>Narrator: Breckenridge-Franklin
Principal Alicia Averette uses a Care
for Kids evaluation form to note
what goes on in the classroom.
>>Teacher: What needs to
happen when we're working
in a group or with a partner?
>>Student: Level 1.
>>Teacher: Very good job, you
are working together; Jermaine?
>>Jermaine: Help them
if they need help.
>>Teacher: Help them
>>I use the CARE for
Kids walkthrough tool,
so when I go in the room I'm
looking for respective interactions
between students and teachers,
a student-centered environment,
student work posted, but
then I'm also looking
at instructional practices
and I provide the teacher
with a copy of the walkthrough tool.
And then we have an
opportunity to debrief.
>>I'm seeing the morning meeting
and the afternoon meetings
and everything, they're being fit in.
You all...
>>Narrator: Since it is part
of the mandated curriculum,
discussion of the CARE for
Kids initiative is a big part
of weekly teacher meetings.
>>Alicia: The sample
schedule we received
from the district has helped plan it,
but it does not allow
for wiggle room.
>>Robben: We can't possibly fit every
single thing that we're expected
to cover in a day along with
the CARE for Kids stuff.
And some teachers get hung up on
it, but at the end of the day,
the moments with the
kids sharing out,
the moments of you
diffusing a problem
or letting kids diffuse the problem
on their own, that's the kind
of stuff that's going to have
the more lasting effect on them.
>>Teacher: Do not let CARE for
Kids be something that's cut out.
If you have to knock
10 minutes off math,
if you have to knock 5 minutes
off science, social studies,
if you embrace the CARE for
Kids and allow that to be one
of the core things, then everything
else falls into place so much easier,
because the students
know the expectations.
They work together well.
They are able to respect
each other, and I was so glad
when our school adopted that,
but now it's mandated and, yay.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.